bandera sucranianas en gerson Jeff logra
la recuperación de una de las provincias
anexionadas por Rusia un lugar
estratégico para poder reconquistar
parte del territorio perdido tras la
invasión de Rusia
pone mucha más presión sobre el sur y
también no solo sobre crimea y las
fuerzas rusas allí sino también sobre la
flota rusa del mar Negro
críticamente esto ha puesto sus sistemas
de armas a distancia principalmente al
alcance una cantidad significativa del
territorio ucraniano que Rusia posee
actualmente
con la recuperación de jerson el
ejército ucraniano buscará después del
duro invierno llegar a las ciudades de
mérito Paul y Mario Paul para ello deben
cruzar al margen Oriental del río nieper
donde Rusia ha montado su línea de
defensa con el abandono de gerson el
ejército ruso trata de reagruparse Y
aprovechar la Barrera natural del río y
evitar que Ucrania pueda cortar su
conexión terrestre con crimea en
palabras para France 24 el analista
Fernando cocho intuye tres posibilidades
en las intenciones del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin Pero hay tres
posibilidades que están manejando en
todos los análisis de inteligencia Y
seguridad uno que abandona gerson como
una especie de Berlín de los años 40
para ser la ciudad a partir de la cual
se pueda negociar con Ucrania un fin de
la guerra bajo la presión de Estados
Unidos China India entre otros una
segunda variante sería que se ha
refugiado en más en el profundo bombas
Putin porque jerson tampoco lo
necesitaba desde el punto de vista
geoestratégico y la tercera que pretenda
dar una señal hacia Ucrania que le haga
bajar sus exigencias a la hora de una
negociación tras la invasión de Rusia
Ucrania del 24 de febrero Rusia logró el
control de gerson tras un ataque
Relámpago casi ocho meses después kiev
logra recuperar un territorio que está
lejos de la normalidad tras haber sido
minado saqueado y cuya infraestructura
clave ha sido destruida